I went to Stanford Hill driving and I'm
sure you've done the same now going to
the hospital and there's a Jewish
section yes now listen to this the men
this is a street in London yeah in
Liberal London the men are walking on
one side of the road and the woman I
said now I'm saying Lausanne ok you done
what you need to do no problem yeah I'm
not having good I haven't got a problem
with that
ok but we're not talking about inside
the synagogue we're talking about in the
streets everything that Islamophobic
people are angry about Islam with is
founded judaism dun dun dun everything
from A to Z Smith hamdulillah
as-salam-o-alaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the D show which is a way of
life we try to put out there for
everyone to see
helping you understand Islam and Muslims
have you guys met Muhammad hijab well
he's here with me on the Dean's show I
seller malecon how you doing my brother
right we had a nice training hand yeah
with this thumb do they love him
especially with your masha'Allah
advanced black belt skills I mean you
definitely know how to take out some
luck I know we worked up a nice sweat
and I can't leave my brother without
some you know saw some proteins and some
juice over here ok ok to replenish to
replenish the body now what's in this
juice ok so I'm gonna have you taste it
you're gonna have to trust me ok all
right so I'm gonna get you some here and
tell me you got some protein in here you
got some natural sugars alright because
we burn off a lot from the training yeah
you know we've been talking a lot about
also nutrition on the D show I don't
know
how's it taste taste actually quite good
spin laughs mmm good good on huh ok I
could've gave you Austin it was I could
have gave you a one of those
proteins protein shakes but if but if
you look at the back of most of these
you have a list of ingredients that you
need a chemistry degree to pronounce so
here three three ingredients okay you
got two banette one banana okay right
for the sugar natural sugar and then you
had two raw eggs again or you want
protein go straight to the source huh
but but but but it has to be organic it
has to be from you know healthy chickens
and then you got some cashew milk BAM
got it done three ingredients now
compare that next time when you have you
know what was that what was that that
one that you had before was a call
Mother's Milk was it muscle milk you
heard of this muscle milk turn that
around and you've got like 20 different
ingredients and what in this and you
don't got only Allah knows what's you
know in there this stuff can really a
lot of it can have a negative effect on
the body yeah so you like that that was
good question
alright good it doesn't taste like I had
any eggs in it whatsoever no yeah many
people are scared of them it was like
raw eggs yeah it was the wrong exit
right that's it all right so we got some
we get has some jiu-jitsu going got some
nutrition here you're not the only one I
mean yeah well I'm not the only fan of
your jiu-jitsu oh yeah yeah because I
mean we've got someone who is actually
of note who is wearing your t-shirt I
mean let's take a look at this oh hey
that that's our buddy we were actually
that's our friend Joe Rogan that's your
t-shirt though isn't it yeah that is our
t-shirt yes Joe surname on that that's
my surname in uh yeah that's my last
name because you made a video right with
one of the with one of the Messiah
before about about Joe Rogan some of his
some of the things that he said about
Islam yeah what do you think this is the
kind of peace offering or is this I
don't know I think you know like I like
I mentioned in the video we did yeah we
really wanted to reach out to Joe yeah
yeah in a benign a nice kind way and
because we're a small community the
community of jiu-jitsu practitioners
and he's done a lot of good and bringing
jiu-jitsu to the forefront he's you
gotta give acknowledge it where the
knowledge meant is due and he talks
about other good topics hearing about
nutrition and other things was what you
got and recipe no no I'm actually if Jo
turns in I'm heat maybe I could turn to
turn him out to this recipe right I got
this actually for my nutritionist Jim
Marlow all right yeah so now Joe he kind
of went out of his Lane he started to
talk about something as near and dear to
over 1.7 billion human being isn't on
the planet Muslims right yeah and
Muslims as you know and I know is
someone who simply has taken a free
choice that he has that I have a woman
has a man hasn't just submitted their
will to the will of the creator that's
it so he started talking about it's not
he started bringing on guests and we
academically without much emotion right
not just you know hurling in the insults
or whatnot
we went and me and the Imam from his
area we went one by one he talked about
FGM female genital mutilation we was
acid attacks you have a lot of those now
against Muslims right in yeah yeah I
mean this is interesting I thought it
really interesting that he was making
the point that acid was thrown by
Muslims on Muslims or by Muslims on
numbers yes where I'm from obviously in
London in is particularly East London
and parts of London that's actually
happening now to Muslims acid has always
been something which has been used by
different peoples to try and afflict
Amin on people ever thought it would be
seen as a Muslim specific problem well
yeah he's dealt with that the imaginary
and we dealt with that we dealt with
many other there was about seven
misconceptions yeah and we cleared those
up anybody who wants to go and see what
actually was talked about they can go
and they can they can look that all you
you're done yeah we did it but now it's
interesting we were we were talking a
little bit and you mentioned Joe and I
that's very interesting he's very
wearing our shirt he's wearing that's
actually my last name on his shirt and
one of his shows that's not Photoshop
mhm that's interesting what do you think
I think honestly this is because Joe
Rogan he is
he's obviously going out he's got a lot
of followers he's not gonna actually put
that t-shirt on unless he done it
strategically I don't believe he's that
kind of a haphazard slapdash kind of
human being so I think it was it was a
message and I think it was a was a
positive message and I think he does
respect Joe Rogan respects people who
are Muslim and are kind of practitioners
of a martial art like he respects khabib
he respects I think he respects you you
respect some other people who's
mentioned Muslims in his in his shows in
his podcast so I think this is a kind of
like a peace offering I do think that
yeah well we really want him to in our
last video we sent that message that hey
if you we'd love for you to talk about
Islam yeah you know we'd love for us to
be a part of the conversation though
right
so to have someone like I mentioned the
Imam that was here last time invite him
eight I can be your hookup
I can make it happen a lot of times
we'll give him a bit of an benefit of
the doubt here maybe you can't reach
these people you don't have the
connections right but now he's got the
connection from the D show he's got hear
me now you and so hopefully what we want
to do with this program how about we go
through some because it looks like his
work you know that he's done has
affected a lot of people and many people
have also brought to our attention some
other things that he said right so maybe
we can go through some of these videos
yeah what do you think and at the end
with the intention that maybe he can
invite you we can go down together go
train some jiu-jitsu yeah maybe he's got
some recipes all the nests is a peace
and understanding right all right so why
don't we start with our with the first
video and then we can go from there
we're gonna have a lot of fun on this
episode god-willing Joe Rogan he can go
through this also be a lot of fun for
him as well and many of his viewers
let's go to the first one and then we'll
get your comments on the intro the term
radical Islam gets thrown around right
so radical Islam simply means I really
take my Islam seriously right it's like
let's draw us a silly analogy you know
should we keep it going and that's good
I mean that's why I'm okay so perfect
right you heard that so pretty much you
can interpret that and I think this one
just the title in itself I don't know if
he if he puts this or people who are
working with
but you know just the title where this
one is that's called the dangers of
Islam right so just by the title itself
it's like you know putting Islam under
the bus and now this person who he
brings on frequently and pretty much
says it pretty much if you practice
Islam that's what it translates to you
know you're pretty much a radical so any
he's pretty much labeling all 1.7
million Muslim or any of those that are
praying giving in charity trying to be a
good human being a good Muslim
he's Braddock all right well first of
all most is really important for us to
understand what he means by radical in
the West when this term is used radical
Muslim or radical Islam it means someone
who is actually prone to violence or
someone who is who has the propensity to
violence or is violent in his or her
actions
that's the connotation that is actually
associated with the term radical Islam
so what he's trying to say is that in
the normative position for a Muslim is
that that particular Muslim is prone to
violence with all people's and this is
his opinion if you if you keep watching
what he says his opinion is that if
Muslims had it their way we would we
would actually be violent to combatants
and non-combatants to to women and
children to anyone who doesn't agree
with our ideology and the first thing is
he's made an assertion isn't it he's now
made a claim where is the evidence for
this claim because making points on a
podcast is one thing not being able to
substantiate it with the primary source
material which is the Quran and Sunnah
is something which is actually should
not be tolerated in an academic
discussion so from this perspective Joe
Rogan should have stopped everything
going on there and said okay so what's
the evidence for this since what Joe
loves is enlightenment thinking
rationalism all these kind of things at
every stage where claims are being made
evidence must be given to substantiate
those claims his claim is that Muslims
are are prone to violence or radical
Islam is Islam in other words what is
common commonly in the vernacular
referred to as terroristic Islam that is
that is synonymous with the Islamic
religion where's the evidence for that
so that's what I would start by saying
because you've made the claim so what's
the evidence for that
and what is I mean so pretty much you
have somebody here who's now you have a
platform mm-hmm that people are trusting
you
yeah right with this information that
you're disseminating yeah and is this
guy is he's viewing facts or fairy tales
or fiction what's this guy saying he's
trying to is trying to imply as we know
from his viewpoint that Muslims are
prone to violence with non-muslims so I
said I said fairy tale fairy tales you
know yes still the this is this is even
this is my fate many cases fairy tales
aren't dangerous you know I can tell
your kid a fairy tale bedtime but these
are I mean this stuff is dangerous yeah
is it it's absolutely dangerous because
if people actually buy into this
propaganda then this will affect the
life chances of Muslims where people
will now compartmentalize the normal I
will say that the normative Muslims the
Muslim who's living by the Quran and
Sunnah who is Orthodox who is living by
the tenets of Islam and the injunctions
of prescribed by the Quran and Sunnah
people will now according to this who
have no knowledge will have no exposure
to Islam see that person as somewhat of
a threat to their way of living to their
person to actually to the actual person
so without evidence this kind of claim
to be actually put on air on a massive
podcast like Joe Rogan's podcast is to
go through a very irresponsible thing
for Joe Rogan to acquiesce to and to
allow it to happen on his podcast how
can you make it right he can make it
right by every time there is a claim
like this by one of those antagonists
and I would call them antagonists well
people are anti Islam first and foremost
to ask them what the evidence for that
claim is and secondly as you mentioned
the beginning of this show he has to now
allow for Muslims to be able to put the
argument because he's never had a Muslim
Pro Islam Orthodox Muslim on the show
putting forward the case for Islam and
answering the questions in the
misconceptions you ready to go it gives
us the call Muhammad hijab and Eddie
from the D show we're coming with our
guys Joe let's do it let's go to the
next one not always have been threatened
in that my head is going to come off at
any minute right my parents grew up and
lived there they didn't die but once the
civil war broke out then it became
lethally dangerous to be Jewish I mean
we were going to be executed
so you never know when we're going to go
from tolerating you two off with the
heads and that's been the history for
the past fourteen hundred years
so pretty much he's time up we just
never know when they're gonna flip we
can translate it it like that right what
are you gonna say so there's two things
of this really important things that
ought to be really stressed one is that
now he's making it as if Muslims are
intrinsically violent and that you don't
know when they are going to actually
become violent the question is why would
that be your assumption of only Muslims
mostly there are segments of Muslims
we're not denying that there are some
Muslims that are prone to violence that
have been violent that continued to be
violent but is that an exclusively
Muslim problem that's point one number
two is where is once again your claim is
noticeable by its lack of evidence so in
other words in order to make this claim
where is your evidence in the Quran and
Sunnah because once again you're
conflating Islam and Muslims Islam as a
religion there is enough in the religion
to make it patently clear to anyone who
has a sincere mind and a pure heart and
who's receptive to listening to these
arguments that Islam is categorically
against the killing of innocent well
let's not even use the word is that
non-combatant people because the word
innocent could be so alcohol is
subjective what does the word doesn't
mean we are saying non-combatants what
is the evidence of this a hadith is
narrated by the Prophet Muhammad war
says men Catalano are hidden let me add
a header a hotel Jena whoever kills a
noncombatant non-muslim will never smell
the fragrance of heaven why have our
translated as non-combatant non Muslim
because this hadith which is in Bihari
is a high hadith authentic has been
narrated upon by Eva Hodja last colony
one of the scholars of Islam major
scholars who wrote that her Barry one of
the major commentaries probably the best
to have written about the body this is
collection and the most authoritative
book of hadith according to Sunni
Muslims
he says I'm ahead here in this hadith
means as in me it means a mahidol most
Atman so in other words any any non
Muslim who is a noncombatant that's the
summary so if the Prophet is telling us
that you you will never smell the
fragrance of paradise if you if you
attempt to murder or if you murder a
noncombatant non-muslim and this man is
saying Muslims are prone to violence and
he's indicating that potentially that
violence comes from the Islamic sources
then does that not run counter to this
particular hadith not regarding of
course the the Quran way says in chapter
60 verse 8 well awesome heart Allah says
lay and her Kamala and in Laveen Allah
meeya party lucuma Dini
well I'm your ado come in the arrow
command table our room autocracy to
Elaine in the law here him opposite in
that Allah does not forbid you of being
nice and kind to those non-believers who
do not take you out of your homes or try
and kill you and that certainly Allah
loves those who are just this particular
verse in the Quran is not abrogated no
scholar has said is abrogated no more
festive no exegete applying the her
musical approach has said that this
verse is abrogated therefore with this
verse and this hadith and of course the
many other verses in the Quran like 532
chapter 5 verse 32 in other verses
it's categorically clear that the
Islamic position is that it is not
allowed it is not allowed from Muslim to
endanger or kill or murder a non-muslim
who is a noncombatant in any case this
runs counter to this man's claim now any
other verses that I mentioned in the
verbatim would have got the Quran where
we have intact tamper free tamper proof
as we had it revealed over 1400 years
ago we have it there's no other book
like it yeah there are references in
there and there is verses that people
will take a lot of times out of context
so how do you now for the skeptic maybe
Joe or one of his followers they said
well what about those horses those
verses how do you read those interpret
those verses well there's two things
that need to be looked at we are not
denied well first of all Muslim position
is not a pacifistic one and that has to
be made patently clear that Islam is not
a religion of pacifism in other words we
do believe that there is a scope an
international scope from international
perspective in international relations
perspective for defensive and sometimes
historically there has been pre-emptive
excursions and that's that's happened
there's been campaigns we're not saying
that didn't happen and we wouldn't deny
that that happened that did happen that
is part of the Islamic corpus there are
verses in the Quran which encourage in
the context of war for aggression there
is for example in chapter 8 verse number
12 and 13 it says so Ilkley fecal-oral
Edenic a for a robber Faldo remove focal
and happy with the booming homunculi
banan which is very much parented by a
lot of these Islamophobes which says
that I will put in the hearts of the
disbelievers terror so you know chop the
hit them back the next and hit them at
the fingertips what is this talking
about it's very very clear that chapter
8 of the Quran chapter mine chapter 4
chapter 2 all those places and those
place in the Quran which talk about
violence reference the context of war no
comment only combat and you know what
the evidence of this is and this is
something which unfortunately and this
man is meant to be an Arab I don't think
he's familiar with these things I will
challenge anyone actually on this yeah
there is no place in the Quran where the
word where killing is mentioned where
killing is mentioned of someone who's a
non-muslim without at least the
beginning of that particular segment a
reference to cattell being made now the
word keitel in arabic it necessitates
fighting from both sides it has to have
fighting from both sides
Ketil means fighting from both sides
whenever the Quran mentions fighting or
killing it only does so when it's clear
that the one who you're fighting is a
combatant that is intending to endanger
you and endanger your life and endanger
your property not in the context where
that person is a noncombatant that is
clear in the linguistic what you would
call the meter this is called the meter
the Arabic meter of this particular word
we tell it cannot necessarily cannot
mean one person murder one person
murdering another person who is a
noncombatant it necessitates in the
Arabic language that there is fighting
from both sides so everywhere in the
Quran which talks about fighting only do
so in the
context of war and this is absolutely
non-controversial considering
considering that that's that is the
foreign policy of almost every if not
every country in the world today it's
absolutely not controversial what
they've made a controversial because
they need to stigmatize the other and
today the other is the Muslim let's go
to the next clip we got it we got quite
a few to go through let's go you ready
for the next one this shirt actually
looks good on Joe doesn't it it does
right it kind of complements his
physique yeah we can get you another one
Joe hopefully when we come down when he
invites Muhammad hijab and myself will
come down or or you can write him we get
you someone else that we need you to
come we'll come together and shout let's
go to the next one very odd because it's
the most regressive it's unbelievable
it's it's very it's a really strange
position to be a progressive who's
reinforcing the ideologies of a
regressive culture that's very ancient
but what's incredible is that they'll
come up with ways to defend this
cognitive inconsistency and hence that's
part of the ostrich parasitic syndrome
that I was mentioning what are some ways
they defend so example let me just give
you a few manifestations of ostrich
logic my friend Muhammad is a very nice
guy and he drinks and he fornicates and
he's very liberal so the idea then
becomes that as long as I can identify a
single exemplar of a Islamic person who
does not otherwise adhere to what Islam
dictates then it's not true that Islam
is bad now this is this is a
manifestation of a more general
cognitive bias your feedback on so I
would say that George is saying you some
enough for the average layman they're
like they can't maybe make out what
we're going to deduce from here right
what what is in layman's terms what
message are we getting from this what
he's trying to say that anything in his
opinion which complies with his
definition of progression is good it's
lam does not apply a comply with that
therefore Islam is bad that's his
deduction he's saying that Islam is
regressive through aggressive that means
it's in
the Stone Age yes in the in the Stone
Age he said medieval religion Yeah right
so his he's saying he he makes his point
quite often actually says very archaic
very medieval very ancient religion this
by the way in logic is called the
genetic fallacy you genetic fallacy is
basically to say and this is a very is a
textbook informal fallacies one of the
first things anyone will learn if
they've studied the basics of logic now
he makes this point over and over again
that this is an ancient religion a very
old religion or whatever I mean so what
does that in does that take away
depreciate from its truth value because
actually democracy is more is more agent
than Islam Islam with the the the big I
that which we would say that the coming
up of Mohammed Salim democracy was
exercised in the ancient Greek period of
time so this was a good maybe a thousand
years before Islam or something actually
more than that so we're talking about if
that was the logic your liberal Democrat
with small island small D right you
believe in liberalism and you believe in
democracy yet liberalism or you can say
democracy for sure is an ancient belief
and he makes this point once again so
does that make democracy a unuseful way
of life so once again the genetic
fallacy is it doesn't actually yield any
positive results the second thing is
here he's allowed for his basically I
would say the the ruler by which and
through which he message measures truth
the post enlightenment age which is
basically after there was a
philosophical age in a 17-2 in lesson
nineteen hundred's whereby some
philosophers came and they preached
certain philosophies of them liberalism
was refined you know lots of
republicanism was was defined refined
lots of popular philosophies were kind
of refined at that period of time and he
thinks the judge of a good society is
that which is complicit with those
particular philosophies my question
would be was to proof for that what's
the evidence for that so you've taken
for granted that the Enlightenment age
is the be-all and end-all is the
pinnacle of human achievement is the
philosophical peak now what is the
objective in an objective way so what is
your way of dealing with that what is
your evidence base for that how can you
provide evidence for that in fact if you
look at the Enlightenment period most of
the Philosopher's actually disagreed
with each other on very core tenants and
that's why you had that conglomerate of
different philosophers always
disagreeing with each other each other
on core issues
thus your measure of truth is is really
a subjective measure of truth which
relies only upon I would say the
post-colonial white man's world and this
is very much the way that the
colonialist the British colonialists the
French colonialists the attack you know
you could say the 'get a lien
colonialists the German colonialists all
of these European colonialists the Dutch
colonialists they actually justified
colonizing glands and that's how America
was actually in an innocence formed so
if that is the case my question to you
very directly Joe would be how can you
prove it
why how can you prove your put your
implicit assumption here that
progression is that which goes towards
Western civilization or its
understanding of enlightenment etc how
can you prove that because we can't just
take those premises for granted don't we
see people judging like Islam and the
civilization of Islam based on two
countries and specifically you have
Afghanistan yeah and Iraq yeah which
have been like blown back into the Stone
Age right so they look at those places
where they've been just bombed you know
and the people who are living peacefully
right
and now minding their own business yeah
now we went over there just turned
everything into how many people died
over the innocent people in Iraq some of
the statistics say is one hundred twenty
three thousand hundred ninety five
thousand people died some say goes up
from there the ranging statistic some
say 125 thousand go goes up to a million
so there are ranges is a person that's a
massive number massive yeah that's a
massive number which cannot be compared
to anything and we're not justifying
about anything that the so that the
terrorists have done so those terrorists
the Islamic terrorists how what they
have done in terms of human casualty
doesn't compare to just that one
particular war so you blew you blew up
the burned the books and the libraries
you know everything was just destroyed
country's upside-down so people think
okay well this is Islam their backward
but I mean what I mean
are there some modern days examples of
some countries that Muslims are living
in I mean what what examples do you give
you buy what do you what I was Elijah
where do you what would you give example
that's a good question so I would say
generally speaking I wouldn't I wouldn't
say that I wouldn't premise this by
saying that the measure of an advanced
society is nothing necessarily yeah
developmental or economic right but even
if we did look at economic even if we
did take that as a as a as a kind of
measure there are some cities and some
countries now in the Muslim world like
in Malaysia like in Indonesia like in
Turkey like in different countries like
I do you say UAE these are countries
which are growing up a rapid rate
however who cares it doesn't do anything
to prove reduce increase the truth value
of Islam or any other religion look at
where America was a good hundred years
ago there was the there was the Wall
Street Crash in the Great Depression
this was literally a hundred years ago I
mean we're talking about the 1920s and
thirties the Wall Street Crash and the
Great Depression does that mean that the
values that you take so so much for
granted were false then and they're true
now there's economic growth and
sustainability necessitate truth I think
this is actually something that a lot of
people do believe that if something if
the values of a particular country are
good then the economics would be good
and that's something he said in another
segment or one of his guests at it it's
a very false kind of fallacious type
logic China should be at the forefront
of our analysis then whatever they
believe it must be the truth because
according to many different economists
they're saying that China will actually
overtake America and its overall GDP and
and will overtake it even militarily in
100 years or 50 years
one more point what about when Islam was
at it's what they call Golden Age yeah
when you look at Islam was now in Spain
in places like this right how advanced
how they sit progressive was a
regressive back then or was the
restitution west of the rest of the
world where people are in the dark ages
what happened if you use this example
well that's a really good question
because I would I would argue that if
you look at for example the time period
of about 410 AD 214 80
five ad this is what is commonly
referred to as the Middle Ages yeah
the Middle Ages is also referred to
ironic ly as the European Dark Ages and
the reason why they call it that is
literally because the Europeans didn't
have at that particular time much of a
cultural economic or philosophical
contribution on the world and in fact
the superpowers of the world were not
the Western world after fourteen eighty
five there was a massive shift because
basically the Europeans found the
Americas and that was the age of
discovery and the Renaissance also
started the early modern period started
there's lots of different things that
aside at the same time but if you think
about the period of time that I've just
mentioned the a Bassett Empire for
example was seen as the strongest human
Empire in the world and so if we use
this the same logic we have to look at
the historical timeline he's one of his
arguments one of the arguments eyes is
panelists often time make is that
economic growth is a measure of truth
well if that's the case we have to look
at all of the time and this is a false
promise anyways but you look at all the
time and the Koran actually informs us
of the fact that there will be days and
there will be times where non-muslims
will be will be successful whether it be
militarily economically and Muslims will
be successful economically militarily
well in his loss Fontana when he says
will kill a yam no there will have been
a Baroness these are the days which we
alternate between the people yes so in
other words there'll be some days which
will be prosperous and victorious and
other days which you'll be which you
will not be prosperous and victorious
yeah all right let's go to the next one
that does not want to criticize this one
segment of the human population that
they think is being persecuted right and
meanwhile if you think about throughout
currently in the world which ideology
persecutes the most number of other
people so if you talk about bloody
borders right Islam has fought with
Buddhist Islam fights with animus Islam
fights with Jews Islam fights with
Christians Islam fights with Tibetan
monks yeah he just makes Muslims are
just bullies they just they're just you
know bloody and blood so they're looking
for a fight all right everywhere you go
we must
are fighting with Buddhists abacus do
everybody just started to you know list
goes on what do you got to say well I
would say to that that that's a really
unfair social that's actually very if
anything's gonna make us angry is that
because frankly the first example he
gave was a ridiculous example he says
Muslims and to the person has fought
with Buddhists Muslims has fought with
Buddhists I mean really if you look at
what the situation in Burma who is
fighting with who who is the oppressed
and who is the oppressor in Burma Burma
is a Buddhist majority country the
rahega
are a Muslim minority living in Burma
according to the UN they are the most
persecuted people in the world this is
he said currently this is current this
is happening today happened yesterday is
gonna happen tomorrow so he picked that
fight exactly that's a really good
question so who picked that fight it was
a fight that was initiated by the
military the Burmese military under the
command of the Burmese government and
with the support of some Burmese people
and be very careful some Burmese people
and particularly the clerics the monks
some monks have come out and the
documentaries online is not it's not
private have come out and actually
justified this genocide that's happening
now and what's happening I've been there
myself on to Cox Mazar which was on the
border with Burma I saw my channel I've
got a video with with women who have
done personal interviews with in Burma
and these women were telling me that
they've seen that that their son's have
been thrown to fires
basically fires were made by the
military and and the Burmese government
as Burmese military held the site their
sons their small infant sons and threw
them into fires and this happened on
mass in villages hope villages were
burnt down I was a witness to that and
it's on my it's on my channel you can
maybe send you a link of that but it's
it's very clear for everyone to see that
actually what's going on is a genocide
the other way around and he they heed
any mentions Muslims are fighting with
Jews is this the argument that actually
Jews are not fighting with Muslims
because frankly if we look at the
situation from
the Balfour Declaration up until this
point in time in Israel or what's
referred to as Israel in Palestine which
we refer to as Palestine which is now
not recognized as a country yeah the
country's been taken over it's been
complete and now settlements are being
built in the West back in in that area
so and these are these are Muslim people
are living there being kicked out of
their homes and being persecuted and in
fact many people would argue non-muslims
would fairly argue looking at it
objectively as Joe would say that
actually this is there's no doubt that
the oppressed here are the Palestinians
and the oppressor are those people that
are are pinching the Palestinians from
every corner so that's what sorry and
then he mentions Christians have fought
Muslims have fought with Christians
almost every historian that I've read on
the Crusades by the way they they see
especially the first and second
Crusaders as a very bloody endeavor
which was obviously initiated by the
Christians and was continual so in other
words can Christians continue doing this
yet the mention of the Crusades has not
mentioned the colonization of the
Americas was one of the most bloodiest
Wars because it was a series of Wars
proxy wars and wars in human history the
colonization of of Spain or my Spain of
the of the Americas of South America and
of of Western European countries to
North America this was seen as is one of
the most bloodiest things that has ever
happened in human history and this is
recent history look what how black
people were treated in America enslaved
for many many years and and racially
abused and persecuted and a lot of this
was pretext using biblical script mm-hmm
a lot of people use Genesis chapter 9
verse 22 to show look you know ham is
the son of Noah and he was cursed and
therefore racism is okay so why is this
discussion not coming out why is this
not being fleshed out why is this kind
of a whole scale like a holistic
approach not being taken sociologically
and more of a wide scale historical
inquiry being made on this why does it
have to be very cherry picked and it's
another logical fallacy by the way
examples to try and prove that Muslims
are unique in their violence in fact if
you look at the most bloodiest if you
look at the bloodiest wars I've ever
happened in history look at the top ten
in terms of casualties you'll find that
the majority of them were done by
Europeans and its extensions so does
that mean to say that white people now
white Europeans are the bloodiest and
most violent people in the world the
historical record shows that they are
but is that something in their genetics
we would make that argument we will say
that's there will be a ridiculous
argument is circumstantial it was
politically circumstantial so I would
say the same thing it's Islam now is
being vilified because of the political
or geopolitical situation which has
happened which has made or should which
is allowed for certain groups to form a
certain terroristic act set to take
place that's politically circumstantial
but if you compare that with what's
happened broadly in history we're very
very clear that actually there's a drop
in the ocean compared to the amount of
people have been killed by Europe in the
Europeans under not only Christianity
but all of those Enlightenment
philosophies that Joe loved so much
including liberalism and including
secularism and including atheism
materialism that Islam has no come
there's no comparison in terms of
casualties yeah it seems like many of
these guests there they're not
thoroughly educated in this area yeah
and they take these headline they
educate themselves because they have a
certain agenda and we know that today
there's a big industry people are making
a lot of money on bashing Islam it's a
it's the Islamophobia industry but then
you have people that so let's say okay
that's coming from you guys the Muslims
right yeah but people can go and check
into this like someone who is genuine
and sincere who's a friend of Joe
Rogan's right his name is CJ wheeler
Minh he's been on the Joel Gonzalez
someone who was also kind of just going
along with what you know the tabloids
and you know superficial knowledge but
he wouldn't take depth and he wanted to
know hold on what is causing these
people to go ahead you know a certain
fringe element to do
whatever extremists ass axe mmm now he's
bringing to light he's saying that no
it's not because of Islam it is
geopolitical you're going exploiting
these people's lands or resources and
then he also is now in the forefront
CJ wheeler Minh Wow guest on the Joe
Rogan show is a friend of Joe Rogan's
he's also now coming out and speaking on
behalf of the Burmese people anyone who
is a sincere genuine person who has a
heart right who really is out for
justice for truth right who's not just
trying to religiously spread hate and
whatnot he's gonna see these things are
these are these this is a rabbit hole
you you go down and you see it's like
wow you know these are things that I
don't really hear in the mainstream CJ
wheeler Minh he's someone now who brings
to the forefront the oppression the
genocide that's going against the
Burmese people same thing with the
designers with the Palestinian the
oppression is going on there and I
really I really think that Joe Rogan if
he starts to bring on people like
yourself people like I I don't think
CJ's been on his show again because he
had an epiphany he's like you know
started to really true Sikh and he went
down this direction I don't know if
he'll have him back again but he if he
brings on people like that like yourself
and others he'll have more of a balanced
approach yeah I I hope so
I really hope because the thing is at
the moment he's panelists his choice of
panelists have been very very selected
he elects a feminist he's chosen people
that literally are anti-muslim expose
them or and it shouldn't be like our
team against your team or one humanity
is that yeah right it shouldn't be like
okay now you know they're the other
they're the bad guys and now we're
trying to pack all that just to stack
all the chips against them so I bring on
these selective guests the what should
be the criteria here and what do we
should what should we looking for for
truth no right for justice for truth
yeah and how do you how would how would
you recommend to Joe right now to
ascertain that truth I'll say to him I I
genuinely believe from what I've seen
with Joe and with his with his guests
especially the ones who talk about Islam
that he's asking from a sincere position
of I'm about to say this in a drovers
resents boy ignorance like he doesn't
know something he wants to know and he's
sincere about that while we say to him
is that
don't rely upon that testimony because
what what would be more conducive for
you is to pick up a translation of the
meaning of the Quran read at least from
chapter 50 up until chap 214 which is a
section called emphasis on it will give
you an understanding of the core tenets
of Islam if you can read the whole book
in in the translation of the meanings
I'll say to him
listen to our side of the argument as
well listen to what we do try and put
yourself in a position because Joe
you're an advocate he's an advocate of
taking it take himself out of the of his
comfort zone yes he's a martial artist
he believes in a sustained growth cannot
be achieved unless you take yourself out
of your son comfort comfort zone and the
same thing applies ideologically you
will not be able to grow intellectually
until you surround yourself with people
you disagree with yeah and that's what
we do on a regular basis in the UK we go
to preschool speakers corner and we
speak with people we disagree partnering
hypotenuse corner and and that is a very
it's actually a liberating experience
because we're able to flesh these issues
out and take the elephant out of the
room so I would recommend for you for
your own intellectual growth after all I
would even say spiritual
psycho-spiritual right I like that and
he can relate to that because in jujitsu
right if you're just training with the
same training partners right yeah you're
beaten out of them right you're not
you're not challenging yourself putting
yourself in uncomfortable positions oh
yeah exactly not gonna grow absolutely
yeah that's a good point let's go let's
continue on how's that we got a few more
let's let's go through these that let
people who are non Islamic who are
fleeing those areas at the front of the
queue first but isn't that isn't that
religious persecution I mean or at the
very least it's prejudiced right I mean
you're you're you're singling people out
because of their ideology or because of
what religion they're from not because
of their past behavior or any predictors
whatsoever about their future behavior
but we do have some statistical
regularity about what types of values
those guys are going to come with so I'm
not suggesting we close the door right
wouldn't that cut in a way I mean just
to play devil's action wouldn't that in
a way kind of put the Muslims in
Toronto hoodoo immigrant would have
picked that city who tried to immigrate
to Canada in the same sort of a position
that your family was in in Lebanon where
you were hiding the fact that you were
Jews
no one has an inalienable right to
emigrate anywhere correct so if you wish
to immigrate to the West then leave
every single syllable that constitutes a
belief attitude position value that is
contrary to ours at the door and then
welcome in my brother but man isn't that
a crazy thing to say to someone whose
entire life and their ideology is a big
part of their identity and who they are
like how they view the world so that's
the structure for which they interface
with other human being but if those
values so let's suppose they agree with
you know in a way I agree with you over
all when I talk about the entire human
population then it would be wonderful if
we did that but from individual to
individual we know about the trials and
tribulations that people go through in a
day to day life and religious freedom
and a religious ideology in many cases
helps people get through the pains of
life it helps them get through the
struggles so now what you have here I
would say this guy is an anti
constitutional issue right because in
our Constitution yeah you have what
freedom of religion so can we say that
this guy is saying basically you you can
come to America but leave your Islamic
yes exactly what do you say about these
well I think that that's more in line
I'm not saying this guy is this but this
that's more aligned with a fascist
belief rather than a liberal belief
frankly because fascism comes from the
the word fascio which literally means to
bundle everyone up together and to rule
over them with the same ideology so in
other words a uniformity and the way
everyone what everyone believes is
required in fascism
people like Carl Schmitt talked about
this one of the fascist philosopher and
Nazi philosophers so what he's saying is
more in line with with that what then is
in line with liberalism to refer to Joel
though he did actually disagree with
this
sentiment which is which is good or good
was cut good was coming out Joe was
standing yes I mean for some some of the
American principles right right he was
saying I was trying to play devil's
advocate but I think his good side that
was coming out yeah I think he's
reluctant to disagree with his guests
Yeah right
he's reluctant to disagree with him but
he was he was playing this devil's
advocate but he was at he was saying I
disagree I agree with parts of it which
implied he disagreed with parts of what
this man was saying sometimes you got to
change your friends brother if you want
to grow you just can't be around the
same people they're gonna bring you down
it's true
this guy's spreading hate man that's
true he's saying basically do you know
what the significance of what he's
saying is that people who are fleeing
persecution because that's what's
happening there they're fleeing person
Muslims who are fleeing persecution they
are dying
women and children who are coming what
if this man had his way because he was
talking about how Muslims would have it
their way this man had his way we'd have
to apostate from our religion in order
to enter into a safe zone yeah sounds
very constitutionalist away or of
pro-constitution
i don't think so i think this man is
very as you've said correctly
anti-constitution yeah let's go to the
next one yes haven't been everywhere I'm
pretty well-traveled I've just I've
never been anywhere like my time the
Middle East where where I've seen not
everybody but certain people value human
life so low so little okay maybe he's
talking about the people where he
visited there but is and my
understanding is right that is he
classifying Muslims as people that he's
never seen such a group of people as
Muslims who don't have value for human
life you talk about Middle Eastern
Middle Easterners or Arabs but generally
speaking I think the conversation went
on to include all Muslims yeah and the
implicit or the subtextual thing there
was that Islam was the cause of this
well this is what they believe and this
is what was kind of echoed before with
the other guests the point being is this
I mean he's saying that he's never seen
a people that have not valued human life
so little well I don't see how that
could be the case when you have police
officers shooting black people in this
country left right and center
for racial reasons I don't see how that
could be the case when America since
2015 which is some two three years ago
was responsible for 1358 drone strikes
in Afghanistan alone I don't see how
that's the case when Stephen green one
of the people that was in Iraq here one
of the one of the human beings that was
a x-drone member of Iraq he killed and
raped a 14-year old Iraqi girl and one
asked the reason why he said I don't see
that he that Iraqis are human beings and
that is the essence of dehumanization I
don't see how he thinks that Middle
Easterners are literally unique in their
belief that a human life is is let is
less when actually the reason why the
majority of human life has blood has
been spilt in the Middle East is
actually because of America itself 123
thousand people have died in Iraq alone
so his point is absolutely null and
voided he's shooting himself right in
the foot with that because frankly what
America has done in the last hundred
years in terms of war Korea Vietnam
Afghanistan Iraq and more and you know
the drone strike campaigns is
unmatchable is absolutely unmatchable
but the thing is this I think they
differentiate in their minds between
people who are close by and people who
are further away because they don't
necessarily see the drones and they
don't necessarily see the people being
killed they don't necessarily have that
intimate empathetic relationship with
with with the rest of humanity what
we're saying is before you point the
finger Middle Easterners and Muslims and
all these people realize very clearly
that there are fingers pointing back at
you and be introspective because this is
a very unfair sociological analysis
before we go to the next one me as a
Muslim who loves Islam submission to the
will of God Muslim is one who submits to
the will of God who loves Jesus who
loves Moses all the prophets that God
has sent with the same message worship
only the Creator not the creation do
good deeds one of the most one of the
first things I think about three and
then we'll go to
one real quick is is the first thing
that one of the cases they'll be judged
on a day of judgment is someone who has
blood on their hands and that's scary I
know it's scary for me I'm sure it's
scary for you I you don't want to come
in front of the Creator in front of a
law in front of God with it with human
life on your hand we know that right
that is gonna be something where you
don't want to take a chance right and
then you have the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him who shows us
through our example that a woman she'll
be thrown in the Hellfire because she
neglected to feed her cat halal ah her
cat she oppressed the cat and because a
net what does that teach us that teaches
the value of not just human life of
animal life and then on top of that you
have the mercy of Islam that the person
who went it was a prostitute was yes who
gave water to the dog to the dog right
look at the sea so these people are
ignorant of Islam yeah you know they're
there in fact this other guy he was
saying that Muhammad hates dogs
you're not like dog yeah I mean Muhammad
hated dogs but he particularly hated
black dogs right yeah so that has no
place in it yeah so this knocks that out
we don't even have to go to that all
right let's go to the next one no you
can slavery this is the horror of
Abrahamic religion generally why we know
these are books we're not authored by a
moral genius the Bible the Quran can't
give you a basis to resist slavery take
it away so this is this is really
interesting because sam harris is
actually written a book called the moral
landscape and in that book called the
moral landscape he writes in a footnote
and one of the ending chapters I forget
which attempt to exactly but he writes
and this is a kind of paraphrase what he
said he says that there is no
neurobiological way of ascertaining
truth and falsehood in other words
objective morality according to sam
harris cannot be ascertained on the
atheistic materialistic worldview this
is not just some Harris's opinion this
is the opinion of Richard Dawkins of
quiz Derrida of Bertrand Russell of
Nietzsche of most post modernist atheist
philosophers that actually objects of
morality cannot be ascertained what's
really interesting is that on the one
hand where they make this patently clear
that there was no philosophical
epistemological base for basically
believing an objective morality
they'll make arguments which are moral
against religion and this is one of the
arguments that they made so he makes he
says that the slavery and whatnot let's
take for granted let's say for the sake
of argument that he's right about the
about slavery generally speaking even if
he was completely right that would do
absolutely nothing for the case of
atheism and absolutely nothing for
disproving Islam however he is wrong on
that because of one very simple verse in
the Quran which most of the children our
children have memorized in so little
ballots in Chapter 90 of the Quran where
it simply says well madaraka Mela Aqaba
facto aqaba what do you know of the good
way what would make you know what the
good way is freeing slaves is the good
way his exact terminology was that there
is nothing within or inside or outside
of the scriptures which allows for the
resisting of slavery the Quran says very
clearly that actually were met at the
rock Kamala Baba what would make you
know what the good way is freeing slaves
is the good way what he is saying
because he is I believe theologically
illiterate I don't think he's actually
someone who reads books theological
books Quran Sunnah hadith and these
things I don't think he actually even
looks at the Bible too deeply I think he
makes sociological cases and generalizes
them on the religion and that's very
very much the nature of what he does he
never close to Quran you'll never really
see this guy caught in the Quran sam
harris sam harris doesn't really quote
though I've never seen him I've never
once seen him quoting the Quran cuz he
knows muddy water for him he's not
trained on this he shouldn't talk about
this this is he is what they call an
ultra craft badarian his non-specialists
talking about something which does not
concern him he's completely talking
about something which is out of his lane
when he does the same thing with
philosophy is the same thing he's a non
specialist in philosophy not specialists
in theology but he talks about both
those matters as if
he's an authority on those two matters
so here he said that the Quran and I'm
also going out the Bible now but we're
talking about the Quran specifically has
there's nothing in it that would allow
us to resist slavery so he would not be
able to basically just he would not be
able to explain away that verse which is
a non abrogated verse of the Quran
moreover I guess what he's trying to say
is because the office of the Quran which
took about what your right hand
possesses and and these things in the
the hadith the various a hadith nasira
what shows us that there were slaves at
the time of the Prophet and we're not
denying that that's the case absolutely
there was slaves at the time of the
Prophet we are saying that the object of
office like the whole world I mean the
whole world at the time absolutely well
slavery ended in American 1865 in in
Britain in 1807 and you could that's
legally once again if we take a step
back and say what is slavery there's a
the International I think it's called
the International anti-slavery
organizations they they actually said
that slavery is defined as includes
child labor human trafficking and
prostitution they've said these things
if we consider these factors and we're
very serious about those definitions and
I would say I would claim that the West
is actually more involved and engaged
with slavery than any other part of the
world and I think that now if you really
care if you really want to make a
difference since we live here that's
something that's not talked about that's
like our little secret America's secret
that there are child sex slave rings in
our country right now
[Music]
up to 300,000 boys and girls are sold in
the United States every year and many of
them don't make it out of the industry
alive there are only 99 known survivors
from the state of Texas in the last 20
years who've managed to escape sexual
slavery when we think of the most
horrific of crimes the ones so morally
repugnant and Barbara you know the
widespread ones that make you question
humanity it can help us cope to believe
they happened somewhere else somewhere
far away that's why this weekend's FBI
prostitution sting in capture of over
150 pimps was so disturbing over a
hundred children rescued sexual slavery
here at home how does it still happen
right so now you want to go ahead and do
some social good
yeah Joe Rogan should step up Sam Harris
to step up while you men trafficking and
talk about human trafficking that's
happening right here in our backyard
yeah but no you got to go talk about you
know hey this is that the other I point
the finger that way so we don't have to
really talk about what's going on at
home it's really interesting cuz Polaris
said that Polaris is what I think is
cool pull ours one of the organizations
they said that America's engaged in
slavery the majority of people that they
enslave in human trafficking human
trafficking forms is that are actually
people of ethnic minority descent so
black people etc those people that are
human engaged in the process of human
trafficking who are who are trafficked
are actually people of ethnic minorities
so they're actually oppressing
minorities enslaving people going back
to what we used to be doing the 1865
days and talking to us about slavery its
llamas I would put this very candidly
only on the record one of the objectives
of Islam is to do away with the
institution of slavery the the mechanism
by which and through which it attempted
to do this which is what I was saying
before was an incremental gradualist
method it wasn't an instant abolition
and we know from history that frankly
when abolitions are attempted just like
in this country when the abolition was
at em set of alcohol people rebelled
against it very quickly if something as
deep and as economically important as
the institution of slavery is in
- woven into the economic fiber of a
society it's not possible if we to pull
the rug under someone's foot so in other
words what Islam came with was an
incremental method using different
things and of them as they can't because
in sort of the touhou chapter of the
Quran one of the there are nine things
or eight or nine things that are
mentioned in the in the verse which
talks about zakat and one of them was
well Federer Club the people who is who
are enslaved so in other words since the
cat is one of the five pillars of Islam
and since the five pillar this
particular pillar must be continued
until the day of judgment we believe
then the e there must have been a
certain amount of money always
designated for the freeing of slaves but
of course sam harris doesn't know this
another thing which is really
interesting is chapter 24 verse 33 of
the quran which explicitly says that if
at that particular time which is
obviously not not applicable to us and
that particular historical time period
something called meketa but can be done
mo kotoba is where you literally have
someone who's enslaved and then they say
to their slave owner they say to the
slave owner i want to be free and i'll
ransom myself okay that person is not a
criminal that person is not someone
who's done anything according to chapter
24 verse 33 and you can look at four
examples of silicon to be or other
tempers here like extra Jesus's that
explicitly say that there's an opinion
that says and this is a strong opinion
going back to the Sahaba and the
Companions the Prophet if this
particular indentured servant because
they're not really slaves in the
colloquial sense because you think of
slaves like racial slavery we'd never
had died in Islam that's never been part
of Islamic never never ever racial stuff
is the Quran is very that's what people
think that's what they have in there
that we're talking about indentured
because at the time there was no prisons
so these people were put into into homes
and imprisoned as if it was a prison
right so that particular person if they
demand yeah if they demand from the
slave owner to be freed then according
to the filler code to be and accorded to
the Sahaba that are related by this
stuff's here they must be freed even if
the the slave owner or you can say the
the
the the the one who's the prisoner the
the one who is imprisoning this
indentured servant declines it this
person can go to a kadhi can go to a
judge and and forcefully be be liberated
or emancipated so in other words Islam I
would argue is the only ancient system
which allowed for the freeing of people
which were either slaves indentured
servants or otherwise there's nothing
else in the history of man that went out
of its way in order to get people out of
the shackles of slavery and into and
emancipated generally speaking whether
it be Muslim or Muslim what comes in my
mind is it is a demon hadatha was it am
I saying the right name where when he
was freed and then he had a chance to go
back to his father to his family he
chose to stay you know out of the love
you know out of the love that he had for
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him yeah so you have a when you put
yourself when you take yourself living
in today's 2018 today's age right and
then you take your back yourself back
1400 years ago when the whole world
everybody is a Muslim slavery days
absolutely messes then Islam came to
free the necks of the slaves right so if
it's LOM just came and said slay a
slavery is eradicate wouldn't work
it wouldn't work you got people invested
with millions hundreds of millions of
dollars you know in slave business
absolutely but then what you're saying
here is now if I'm correct now in every
which way you turn and you just made the
road that now it penetrated the hearts
yeah so people gave this up absolutely
from the love of their heart absolutely
not like that it was forced in this
country and to this day people are like
these people should be slaves right and
you have all this racism is this yeah
but there are certain situations where
people will be forced to free slaves for
example in Islam if someone had sexual
intercourse with their wife in Ramadan
they have to free a slave if someone
took the heart which is mentioned in
chapter 58 of the Quran which they call
their wives that they say they you're
not you're basically not you
like my mother in other words you're not
sexually compatible with me or something
it's a very specific kind of insult free
after free slaves yeah if they did if
they didn't oh yeah they have to free it
so there's so many things in Islam which
you're forced to free slaves if you do
certain things then these slaves also
slaves become governors then they become
scholars they become like absolutely had
people have high prestige people will
not understand this but some people
because we just said that for example if
someone was enslaved or an indentured
servant don't you serve in there
literally whatever yeah that's what they
were they were indentured servants if
they were in in the house of someone who
was imprisoning them and they had the
rights over them and I say and they
decided that they wanted to do more kata
by which is this basically it's a ransom
their ransom ransoming themselves they
want to be freed and they had that
opportunity and they didn't take it the
question is why would those people don't
take it a lot of the the particular
slaves at that time I would mention
servants they didn't take the
opportunity because they they were
getting free accommodation yes now
that's why a lot of them continue to be
Malik like the Mamluk Empire was
actually the mom looks there was two men
looks one in Egypt and one in India but
the ones in Egypt and in India both of
those was work work of a slave car or a
tribe or slave socioeconomic grouping so
they were socioeconomically the lowest
of the low yet they were made into the
highest of the high mm-hmm so it's not
the same as the Western experience a lot
of people think they generalize history
okay what would happen to the
transatlantic slave trade where you had
black people shift off from West Africa
yeah that's the same thing as what
happens let's not okay before we go to
the next one people are automatically
automatically gonna see what's going on
with this insane state right they use
these fringe elements and then some
things in Libya yeah what do you say to
that I say to that I mean it's really
really interesting the I is I Islamic
State we shouldn't call it that we
should cool - or something but whatever
they want to call themselves about the
insane stay in state that sounds good
and saying hey those particular
individuals
first and foremost I've never seen such
an extreme fringe in my whole life to
the extent whereby our hours to an
interview in Arabic with
one of the Mogul dimensions of their
names but they let's say they're of the
same ilk as Osama bin Laden right they
of the same ilk meaning they have the
same kind of they believe the same
things and one of their leaders said we
don't consider this is actually said he
said we don't we call a we call this
group back to Allison all Jamar
so they don't consider them Sunni
Muslims some scholars don't consider
this particular faction it's called
[ __ ] Muslims they look some scholars
have said that at all so that's one
thing those people who have said that
they don't cuz their enslaving and this
is what this person said in the
interview they're enslaving their women
so in other words that particular is
another faction in the Assyrian war
which is let's say associated with
extremism that other faction was
associated is saying the person is in
charge of affection that there is
slaving our woman what does that show it
shows actually to be frank that no one
sees these people as doing something in
line with Islam not even Osama bin Laden
himself and I'm saying this on the
record not even him and we know that
what he stands for and all that kind of
stuff is completely against mainstream
Orthodox Islam according to all of the
institutions of Islam but not even he
would see what they're doing is in line
with Islam mm-hmm absolutely not
yeah I could mention names and all these
kind of things but we won't go into that
wrongness a discussion but the point is
this is such a fringe element of Islam
that it's really not worth mentioning as
a point of reference
yet some Harris consistently mentions it
as some kind of point of reference it's
academically disingenuous because
frankly there are institutions in Islam
and the Islamic quote all of the
institution's you know one thing has
reunited all of the Muslims against them
is Isis there's nothing that I have
United all the Muslims against them more
than Isis has but they still pretty
bringing up this fringe element every
Muslim early drinks yes are dirty every
Muslim organization from India to Saudi
Arabia to Egypt to Saudi air to all of
these in Mauritania all of the Centers
of intellectual power
Slama quote which she's not even
familiar with I'm sure Sam Harris is not
familiar with those places and those
institutions
all of them have categorically condemned
Isis all of them so this there is a
consensus on this issue yeah and yeah
he's using it as an example so you're
actually disregarding all of the
institutional what he would call fatwas
religious rulings and verdicts of
everybody in the Muslim world all of any
scholar worth his you know any scholar
in the Muslim world has said the same
thing yeah
so how can we ignore all of that and say
okay well these these disband of people
and Lybia the same thing is obviously
the Libyan thing have the same ideology
Libya there's Isis in Libya so we're
killing two birds want some of this
because frankly the ISIS ideology is so
far removed from mainstream Islam that
absolutely everybody has condemned him
yeah I don't see how he that is flown
above his head they kill more Muslims
absolutely yeah they actually have done
more harm than any to Muslims myth
before we go to the next point I mean
there was an FBI released some data
talking about that the book that most of
them were found carrying with them was a
showing how ignorant of Islam this group
the insane state is of Islam yeah a
dummies guide for understanding it's
like yeah so this is a you know really
bizarre when you hear these things where
people are just tuning in and they're
wondering we got our resolve ik jujitsu
we're reaching out to our brother Joe
Rogan hopefully so he can invite some
scholars onto his show and give the
Muslims perspective have a fair and
balanced approach to these very
important topics because again so once
again these things helped fuel the
division they helped feed into the hate
the misunderstanding and that leads to
the violence we've seen a lot of it we
can discuss that more towards the end
let's go to the next one you ready
Charla KO bida now that'd be ID a I
think in my nature I'm not sure but I
don't speak Arabic and the idea is that
there are no education not have any
innovation not the innovation that they
are to use like Toyota truck
yeah like for example self-defense king
of South had a hell of a time right okay
so Saudi Arabia was founded by the eben
sound family in so this is very
interesting I mean you have Joe Rogan
who has a lot of knowledge in many
different areas yes he's one of the best
fight commentators if you want to talk
about jujitsu or mixed martial arts he's
an expert there yeah and obviously we're
assuming that he wants to learn so if
you learn you grow but now when you have
someone like this he comes on and he's
just so you know what he's got the
British he's got accent like you right
yeah and and you're laughing because
you've dedicated your life to this Deen
to this way of life to studying Islam to
learning to go how do you feel when you
have someone when you see someone like
this coming off like man he's like you
know mister share you know we caught
he's a scholar like he's you know he's
really educating Joe Joe's coming to him
for the knowledge well first of all I
wouldn't said that he here my life or
like if I was anything like that I would
I would wish to have done that
uh-huh well I asked first foremost but
secondly this guy he's trying to use the
word Buddha yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
didn't have to pronounce he didn't know
what it was he did not spell it he said
he doesn't know the Arabic and then he
falsely he falsely gives a false
definition well he gives the first
definition to Joe Rogan who swallows it
wholesale and then he accepts it without
questioning it and then he kind of
attacks Islam based on it I would say
this is this is not the way to educate
yourself on any topic it really isn't
the way he was trying to say was be that
and he what he's trying to say here is
that Buddha is actually an innovation of
any kind so technological innovation and
he's trying to imply that Muslims are
averse to technological innovation of
course the hadith of aisha radi allahu
Hana is of Muhammad she said that he
said when death a feigning I had my life
I mean who for horrid whoever innovates
in our religion what's not in it then it
is rejected so this is a way of like
preserving the religion right it's all
religious stuff it's only it only
relates
two religious injunctions so in other
words we cannot invent a new religious
injunction or put into the religion of
Islam what's not in it because we
believe Islam is perfect it's complete
the Quran says in chapter five verse
three aloma a camel to Allah come Dina
come o alikum now materially - like
honestly medina so i have perfected your
religion i have completed my favor upon
you and I've made Islam a religion so
it's not a matter of of technological
and this is such a blunder I mean it's
such a blunder that I can't believe that
he's got someone like this on the show
educating him on a very important topic
and then he's swallowing it all up
wholesales really it's actually quite
embarrassing it is so now if the person
is making a major blunder here
imagine all the other mistakes and
you're swallowing them whole and then
not just that it's different you guys is
dangerous okay you guys having a
conversation then you go in spewing it
but you got a massive audience now yeah
it's true and it just doesn't stop there
continues on he just continues on we got
we'd be here all day
yeah you know going we've seen so many
blunders that I mean enough it's just
one example of it by such a blunder to
be honest with you such a blunder let's
get through a couple more and then we'll
close it up give some good advice
hopefully Joe Rogan is to get to him and
he'll have a open mind to go through
these things and this is this is all in
the essence of reaching out to him and
his audience so for genuine people who
are sincere who really want to know they
come into the musca that's what we're
dedicated the Deen show is dedicated to
help clear up these misconceptions and
deliver the truth to you about Islam and
bringing you experts who know Islam live
Islam instead of some guy who's maybe
reading a cereal box against some
headlines and he's coming out with a
nice the the accident kind of pulls you
in in whatever team that were on right
and when you're on a team that has in
arguably in 2017 the most archaic
mainstream ideology that's that's Islam
right I mean if you you stop and think
about how ancient is it how in its
practice is the way especially when it's
in use in radical ways the way women are
forced to
the way in Saudi Arabia I think up until
really recently they weren't allowed to
drive right now they're alive in the
last two or three years yeah there's a
lot of like stuff in it that we would
think of as being a part of a bygone era
of human beings what are you guys saying
well first and foremost I mean he made
the same genetic fallacy as I said
before he repeats this argument quite
often it's an archaic religion it's an
ancient religion this is called the
genetic fallacy it's a logical informal
fallacy which means that you're looking
at the origins of where something came
from in order to show that it's false
that's not necessarily a way in which
you can prove something is true or false
and moreover he was actually inaccurate
in his conceptualizing of Islam as the
most archaic mainstream mainstream
ideology the most are in fact democracy
as of mentioned before and the idea of
the demos and Crotty er which are two
Greek words meaning people power
originated much before the Prophet
Muhammad's coming so that's actually
false from historical perspective is
false philosophical is false
on every level but then he went on to
talk about women women's dress which he
which I think you've covered it before
but we can kind of talk about once again
and he said this more than once whatever
he talks about and I've noticed this
whenever he talks about Islam he's got
this two or three things that he talks
about it's the fact that it's an ancient
religion the fact that he says radical
elements not being specific of what is
radical about it why he thinks his
radical we're not giving every evidence
and then he talks about women's dress
and he's been known and shown to be
quite derogatory and offensive frankly
with his his insults of Muslim women's
dress the question is on a theism and I
don't believe he's a person of religion
anyways on atheism who dictates what who
should wear what it's all a social
construct at the end of the day right no
one can prove that woman can wear this
or should wear that or should wear denim
jeans or should wear tight jeggings or
I'm saying a miniskirt or whatever it
may be if you look at the sociological
landscape in the Western world and there
is this conception that the more a woman
shows the more she's in fact free and
liberated this conception is actually
very much commodifying and objectifying
of women anyways and you could say that
the capitalistic enterprise in the
Western world has forced women to
actually actually forced pressured and
influenced women on every level to wear
certain things which would be more
economically which would help the
economic onna me actually bolster itself
so in other words one could make the
argument that the fact that the woman
has to take off clothes in order to to
actually fit into a sociological norm
that has been constructed by certain
people probably men in the patriarchal
society that shows itself that women
have been forced to take off their
clothes so if you have a problem with
women being forced to put on or take off
clothes then once again you should
address the same issue as frankly even
radical feminists address which is the
commodification of women which leads to
rape some say that this is actually a
direct causation not just a correlation
it leads to rape it leads to different
kinds of social ills it leads to
objectifying women but men seeing her
having entitlement it leads to a range
of different social problems and he has
not really said what he's doing is it's
called an aesthetic the value judgment
he's looking at something say I don't
like the way that looks why cuz you're
not used to it you live in California or
you live from Boston I don't know where
he lives and he's used to seeing certain
aesthetic things things look normal to
him things look abnormal to him you know
we had that you can have a drink of
coffee you can have a drink of tea you
might not like coffee you might not like
who cares
it's your subjective opinion have you
got anything to substantiate to us that
women ought to wear this or we women
ought to wear that or is it just the
fact that you're a post-colonial a white
man living in the Western Hemisphere
that thinks that women should wear denim
jeans and short skirts and you're trying
to enforce that on a different part of
the world which has religious precepts
which encourages women to be more modest
if it is this if it is the latter then
you have no case my friend I would say
to him really and truly you have no case
matter however your opinion is as
valuable as as it is for you so it's
subjective your subjective opinion
you're entitled to have it no problem
but I wouldn't go as far as to insult
now women that are wearing something
that you're not used to were seeing and
there's a ton of I mean there's a ton of
videos out there and he can go to the
Muslim woman himself yeah and hear what
they have to say they feel liberated
absolutely they feel free now right be
dressing in this modest way there's a
quote that really struck home Norman
Finkelstein you've heard him he quotes
that people who came over to America at
first they had three layers of clothing
right right and they saw the natives on
the land they're pretty much almost you
know had nothing on and they thought
they were pretty much savage but then
Norman dr. Norman Finkelstein and he
says now how dare we but how dare we
insult well you know the Muslim women
right and here and now we're half naked
and they're dressed he's talking about
the Muslim woman and we're saying that
they're you know backwards some in this
perhaps that's a really interesting
thing is that's what dr. Norman's a sort
of him yeah yeah yeah he's very he's a
he's a good person also for dr. Joe
Rogan to come on he would be brilliant
to talk so he's brilliant yeah excellent
especially anti-zionist thing yeah if he
wants if he wants an expert in this area
because he talks he has some Zionist
friends that come on if he really any
Jewish huh he's Jewish and he's Jewish
his family they were from the home of
the Holocaust that is a fair and
balanced approach someone who doesn't
mainstream media isn't scared to touch
him right Joe Rogan he's independent why
don't you bring him on yeah absolutely
brilliant but I was gonna say what what
Joe Rogan commentary boils down to is
actually not only just an aesthetic
value judgment but actually a
post-colonial narrative which which
really is that the white man wants the
rest of the world in his image like the
the when I say the white man was talking
about the cover the scales were the
post-colonial archetypal man who has
seen that the Western
experience is the pinnacle of human
achievement they want the rest of the
world in their image moreover what's
interesting as I think I was mentioning
to you before they're actually we've
talked about months we know nuns wear
head jab in a sense I mean they were the
equivalent of a hijack what's not known
as that her any Jewish women if you look
and just go online and check her ad
Jewish like Orthodox Jewish women they
actually we're in the hub which is the
face covering as well now these are not
Jewish people keep it fair and balanced
why don't you talk about them they have
asked his Jewish friends to talk about
absolutely why not yeah even if if your
argument well they're a significant
minority well frankly the woman who wear
in the cob with the face covering in the
Muslim community are also significant
minority just the fact that you have one
point eight or whoever is good as a few
billion Muslims and maybe about thirty
to fifty million Jews might this make it
disproportion terms of numbers but terms
of ratio might be the same so if you
have a problem with those practices I
don't see you making the same argument
with Jews I've never had use in your
show why don't you spoke to won't you
bring this they usually make these
arguments also about you know Sharia is
in for trading and taking over they got
no-go zones yeah talk about that don't
they have places now that you actually
have you know places where it's strictly
for Orthodox Jews in in your part of the
world absolutely yes that's right yeah
you've witnessed this absolute how -
they had a good discussion and speaker
schooling with one Orthodox Jew these
are peaceful discussions you're having
yeah brilliant discussions he wasn't
offended people can come watch they so
want to talked about one issue that
you're experienced forget about religion
your experience as Muslims I'm always
being told we need to integrate as
Muslims we need to integrate integration
we heard this all the time now listen I
was quite surprised and shocked so wait
a minute why let me tell you why I went
to Stanford Hill driving and I'm sure
you've done the same no let me let me
I'm not saying it's bad it listen to me
carefully
Rovio's driving around I saw our
ambulance
it's a bit different isn't it yeah well
in a minute what I example is so
different I realize he's a Jewish
ambulance but then I go into the I'm
told going to the hospital and there's a
Jewish section where hold on there's
more 203 now I see the men in one side
of the road and the woman walk in the
other side of the road now listen to
this the men this is a street in London
yeah in Liberal London the men are
walking on one side of the world and the
woman are said now I'm saying Lausanne
okay you done what you need to do no
problem
yeah I'm not having good I haven't got a
problem with that okay but we're not
talking about inside the synagogue we're
talking about in the streets everything
that Islamophobic people are angry about
Islam with is founded Judaism dun dun
dun everything from A to Z well lie
everything that Islamophobic people are
angry about Islam in our in Judaism
that's something I'm making as a common
everything it's just me and that's a
lesson we want to take we bring up
Jewish people or bring out a bit yeah
we're not of trying to offend people
we're now trying to divide people
absolutely not but the point is that
there's miracles Stoke Newington in
London this area's in North London this
area is a Jewish kind of Muslim majority
but this is what's it called Stoke
Newington oh yeah this area North London
you have synagogues Jewish synagogues
what I was really intrigued in finding
is that there are there are actually
ambulances which are Jewish only
ambulances police forces maybe not
legitimately all I say illegally police
but pseudo police forces which are
Jewish police forces not only that
you'll find that men and women are
segregated in terms of on the roads of
England in the world of London so this
is Jewish Sharia police hey yeah in fact
there's there's actually a hospital
called the raw free I think we're all
free hospital in London which there's
that there's a Jewish only area yeah so
if I go into that area and I'm not Jew
it's like a kosher area or something
right so if I go to that area and I'm
not Jewish
they'll say get out of it you're not
welcoming this in this
section four yeah real for it says
Jewish only area no honestly we're not
saying that look Jewish Jews are not
allowed their own space my opinion on
this my personal pin is there this
should be allowed to do whatever they
feel comfortable with that kind of
things we haven't got a problem but be
fair in your analysis because when it
comes to a liberal now trying to enforce
they were chemical the muscular
liberalism Joe Rogan should be thinking
okay well is there only move is this a
Muslim specific and this is something I
want him to apply criticality I want him
to ask the question is this a Muslim
specific phenomena or is this actually
something which is cross-cultural cross
religious it applies to more than one a
religious or cultural group and if you
ask that question you realize actually
it does apply to more than one group and
Jews and Muslims Orthodox Muslims and
also acts Jews are very similar in many
ways most of his criticisms and things
would actually apply to Orthodox Jews as
well yeah I think we got one more okay
and I think for the record I hope that
this for people may be joining us late
maybe you tuning in watching us on one
of the satellite channels were on and
we're trying to as you interpret I think
you did if I'm not wrong as this is a
peaceful gesture yeah yeah for sure for
sure Joe Rogan who has one of the top
podcasts in in America he's kind of
stepped into a lane and we're trying to
help him offering our services yeah we
can help him we want him to grow yeah
yeah you know we want him to talk with
us right and learn so we're making
ourselves available and hopefully he'll
reach out and how can people also help
to get this maybe to him right we this
is where you know many a Muslim and
other people who are truth seekers who
really want him to be fair and balanced
they can also help too yeah maybe put on
his our life he's got Instagram put put
on his Instagram messages or comments or
put her in his comments in his next
podcast coming up make it clear that
they you know they want to see a
discussion with a Muslim Yessica Lee a
fair-minded Muslim who's engaged in
these kinds of discussions anyways yeah
and if you got like you know tens of
thousands of
Muslims stepping up and say come on Joe
let's go let's do it let's do it let's
go to the next one so it's like Baptists
going after Catholics
yeah now you are you've talked about
this topic in particular excessively you
have some videos and then you can also
let us know where people can if Joe
himself or others they want to see some
of your work well or Charo is just my
name Muhammad head job yeah like the
hijab hij yeah yeah yes right so um I've
got a playlist unlike my discussions
with Shia I'm a sunni obviously I come
from that background but I mean when you
say Sunnis people know what does that
mean Sunni is an abbreviation of Allison
lateral Jamar hello Sonoma means
literally following the sunnah of the
prophet and the Jamar of the Sahab of
the Companions of the Prophet so in
other words we follow the Prophet and
the Companions thereafter Prophet
Mohammed Mohammed Salim and the
companions are after that's what the
name is the derivative from and Shia
literally means sect or it could mean
group or could mean yeah it could mean
faction no I am so it's a sect which is
an offshoot of the mainstream suddenly
position so we've had this kind of
discussion with Shias I've had maybe
three formal debates with with Shias and
many informal debates with with Shias
it's on my channel but the point is this
is really interesting because what he's
doing is reducing very complicated
differences and frankly they are
complicated differences too always said
the success is different well actually
there's a range of different issues what
that does it thumbs down the audience
now it's it dumps down the situation for
the audience the people don't really
know things but what that indicates
about this particular this particular
person is that they're not informed in
that in that way theologically about
differences between she and so no
they're not informed about Islam in that
in a in that way which was you which is
required in order to make a commentary
of Islam so I would and once again this
is probably a good place to say you know
for
Joe himself if he really is serious
about identifying himself in educating
himself on this issue of Islam because
Islam is a big thing it keeps coming up
in his conversations people that's the
point now why is it okay now you're a a
martial arts commentator eat I'm on
nutrition martial arts yeah it's like
this out of nowhere islam a whole
podcast dedicated on islam it's not like
it just came up in a conversation of an
opinion right yeah you don't have to
have an opinion
so now you open the beador right for
some constructive some academic
criticism what we did we didn't insult
him we didn't go to you know put him
down or what now but we're saying you're
out of your lane come make it fair and
balanced make it fair and balanced i
think it's needed now in order because
frankly there is a reputation on the
line also uh of his podcast because if
he wants have a reputable podcast which
which features a variety of different
opinions on academic topics which is not
highly biased frankly on on this issue
there does require the the doesn't need
to be there needs to be this at least
this um this different kind of you need
to bring different people in huh and so
we'll say I'm bringing the pro Muslims
in people that are awful Orthodox
Muslims believe in Islam and that can
actually afford a case for what we
believe in why I believe in it
I thought you can make your decision and
then you make your decision tell us
because you do that the facts are there
anyone who goes looks into it you have a
lot of hate speech leading to hate
crimes you have a lot of mas being that
not just vandalized but fire bombed you
know people being killed in Britain you
had something recently a few incidences
his right man came and with the car and
just you know ran over that one Osbourne
that's right and can you correlate this
directly with people who are out there
in this industry of fueling hate yeah
and division that was one himself he I
mean he was looking at a particular
person called Tommy Robinson it was it
was a vehement he was someone who's an
advocate for Tom Robinson who used to
watch his videos on his iPad he had a
history that indicated I used to watch
this person he's a right-wing hate
preacher we that's where he is
islamaphobe and so that kind of you
could you could argue that through
inference of the best explanation
he must have been radicalized by this
kind of right-wing commentary and then
he became someone who actually killed
some people Muslims we know the value of
that we cut off the inner I mean right
now people as soon as you see them
connected to some of these groups and
someone says something online that seems
like a threat potential threat you got
you know the authorities knocking on the
door exactly but now when these
neo-nazis when you know the KKK when
these type are our spewing this this
venom that's a poisonous venom you don't
see no one knocking on the door that's a
double standard that's a problem that's
a real problem that's incorrect yeah
yeah so what do you what do you think
now when people say okay well this is
freedom of speech well there's no such
thing as now you know this hates be it's
it's freedom of speech you're trying to
limit our speech brother well well I
would say to them is that this is
actually something that Joe Rogan
mentions quite a lot of freedom of
speech there was a recent interview with
someone called Jordan Peter said and
capac khatma Kathy Newman Newman or
something I listen in channel 4 and
where this topic of freedom of speech
came up the question is what are the
parameters of freedom of speech because
freedom of speech is a precept which
which is an offshoot of liberalism
liberalism is the idea liberalism the
different kinds of liberalism is like
economic liberalism there is a social or
physical liberalism you can say there's
you know a political liberalism of
checks and balances and what John Locke
was talking about Montesquieu on all
these things
the truth is on a social level
liberalism is as Jay s Mill said the
ability to do whatever you want so long
as no one as you don't harm anyone else
this is called the hum principle yeah so
you can do everyone so long as you don't
harm anyone else what is harm because if
we're talking about philosophical
liberalism then when we'll talk about
freedom of speech we have to kind of
tether freedom of speech we have to
refine this concept of freedom of speech
we have to qualify it with this harm
principle otherwise you'd have what
you'd call utilitarianism which is what
Jeremy Bentham believed in which is the
greatest amount of good for the greatest
number of people which is what j/s mill
refined so the point is this idea of
liberalism is is actually refined by
jeaious mill with this hum principle
what is harm one could argue that
example using the n-word
it's helpful that's what we don't do it
even if some comedian felt it funny to
use the end with some white comedian
felt it funny to use the n-word most
people in society would say well look at
the historical timeline look what we've
done to black people and now you him
trying to humiliate black people with
something you know it's gonna activate
them so they're not gonna accept the
n-word it's socially unacceptable really
and truly the parameters of freedom of
speech are defined socially or socially
constructed what we're saying is that if
there's a significant number of Muslim
people that are offended with certain
things like for example he keeps
machining the drawing of cartoons if
they're offended by that if they find
that harmful right if you're saying that
that doesn't matter then I would argue
that you're going against the harm
principle because you're defining harm
isn't the only harm that matters is the
harm that I define that matters so you
wouldn't say the n-word
you wouldn't say certain things about
Jewish people you wouldn't make
Holocaust jokes would you make would Joe
Rogan's ever make Holocaust jokes no
even he's a comedian he was a stand-up
comedian would he ever dare make
Holocaust jokes no because he knows it's
gonna offend us challenged him yeah I'll
sure if he's really about be nice Pete
if you if you believe in absolute
freedom of speech and Reza this other
guy that he had on the train he also
said he believes in freedom of absolute
freedom of speech I challenge you to
make a few jokes about the Holocaust a
few jokes about the n-word a few jokes
about other communities homosexuals make
a few jokes about homosexuals they say
something about homosexuals so you know
you're not going to do that because
actually Society has defined for you
what is appropriate freedom of speech
what is inappropriate freedom of speech
so why you so upset with the left-wing
people that our being socially
consistent and philosophically
consistent that don't necessarily want
to harm Muslim people and this links to
another precept which is really
interesting called the tyranny of the
majority now in democracies one of the
thing that most democratic commentators
said was a problem was what is referred
to as a tyranny of the majority when you
have a majority of people that believe
in one thing and I'm a minority of
people that believe in something else
and those majority of people actually
exploit somehow or take advantage of the
minority of people that could take
different forms and in our discussion
today week essentially does take the
form of insulting or saying something
which would be insulting
to a segment of people which in this
case would be Muslims what what media
streams have to understand if they want
to be democratically consistent is that
actually what they should be doing is
amplifying the voices of the minority in
order to create an equilibrium if what
they're doing is counter to that and
actually amplifying the voice of some
segments of the majority which is
actually antithetical to the minority
that does anything but exacerbate the
situation and create a higher
exploitation for the minority which is
anti-democratic if you think about it
philosophically so Joe Rogan frankly in
his in his commentaries and with the
people he's brought on the on on the
bandwagon frankly with panelists has
been nothing but fueling a tyranny of
the majority that I would claim is
happening already in America in the West
and being therefore by extension quite
anti-democratic if he wants to be
consistent and he wants to humanize him
he doesn't want to dehumanize be human
beings he wants to allow human being sir
to celebrate the human dignity and what
they should do what he should do is
allow for the counterbalance amplify the
voices of the minority even if you don't
like it
Noam Chomsky says I'm really interesting
Noam Chomsky is a very famous liberal
kind of thinker I think it was one of
the most quoted people in in a certain
time period in in in certain
publications and books he said you don't
really believe in freedom of speech
until you allow the people you despise
the most to say what they want to say
bring us on Joe that's it gisado
yeah go ahead finish that's what I was
gonna say right this is the longest for
the record now this is the longest show
that we've done the Dean show is going
on over almost 11 years
I'm duel almost 600 I think episodes
that shows that but this shows that our
are sincere and genuine love that we
have for the people to really connect
with us you know we didn't go on a
bashing spree with Joe you know you know
we try to connect to him in kindness in
a benign way we made our
record now history weed this the longest
show right because we covered a lot he
had a lot of guests a lot of different
topics but too much you know
to go over in just one day let alone
just one show but I think you did a
great job come to LA now let us spend
we're almost at the two-hour mark okay
let's spend a few minutes because what
these people do in this industry and
it's a big-money industry almost a
quarter over a quarter of a million
dollars right people don't have jobs
they're looking to get a job so they
join the industry of Bashan Islam right
because then the limits the boundaries
haven't been set like you know you can't
go ahead and criticize or say anything
about what these groups that you said
but here you can so until that's defined
people are just having a free-for-all
and they're making money some hair is
big money these people if you look to
the route they're making money man and
it's a money industry right so now we're
hoping that Joe Rogan right his
sincerity right his humanism his the
human side can come out he can bring
Assad he can bring on someone qualified
to target to keep it to set the
equilibrium like you say but now what
they can't attack or you don't see him
attack is the main message of Islam
let's spend a few minutes talking about
the main message of it's not yeah I
think this is really important if Joe is
watching that you know the basics of
Islam right the basics of Islam is that
as you've mentioned and you articulated
mashallah very concisely unlike me I'm
very good time but it's basically
submission to Allah its submission to
Allah so cannot we believe Allah is a
god that we believe is the only God
worthy of worship it's not a new God or
moon God or whatever
it literally Allah comes from the Arabic
word al-ilah which means their God in
other words the only God worthy of
worship is the same God that all of the
prophets before like Moses and Abraham
and Jesus and all these prophets came
and believed in that God and they
preached to the people to believe in
that God and worship in that God
and so all of the prophets we believe
came with that in Chapter 7 verse 150 a
of the choruses well yeah unless in the
Rasul
la Commedia me on that the Prophet is
told to us to say that all human beings
I am your messenger for all of humanity
for all of humanity so the distinction
between the Prophet Muhammad and all of
the other prophets that came before him
is that he came for all of the human
beings whereas all of the other prophets
came for their locality as it says in
the book of Matthew do not go in the way
of the Gentiles for I was only sent to
the lost sheep of Israel I say that
Jesus came to for the lost sheep of
Israel Moses came for the for the
Israelites etc prophet Muhammad came for
all of the human beings in the world and
he came to spread this message of
submission to the one God who created
the universe whose sustaining and
maintaining the universe and who set the
test for human beings on this earth and
and frankly this test is to either
believe in this God and to worship in
this God wholeheartedly or to think
somehow that you came into existence
from nothing by nothing and you're going
nowhere and we would say that the first
thing that I've mentioned here is more
rationalize Abel is more spiritually
invigorating it is it appeals to human
beings more psychologically and
rationally and therefore from our
perspective it's the best thing to
follow so we are Muslims speaking of
that I think it was in your part of the
world Oxford and they did a study I
think they had like 50 to some
researchers from anthropology yes right
you know the study yes yes and they
concluded that it's innate for the human
being to believe that's a really good
point that's right the study was done in
2011 you know what yeah I miss the
Oxford anthropological society mmm it
was a cross it was a multidisciplinary
study that spanned for many years in
fact it included many different
countries and in said it summarized it's
not just to study there's many different
studies which had the same result that
the belief in God is innate is intrinsic
is psychologically predisposed human
beings are predisposed to believing in
God and that's why you'll find for them
if human civilization human beings have
believed in a god
whether it be Allah or any other God by
another name but they human beings
either have been historically wanna see
a snake politic atheism yes it has
existed from from very long time ago but
has only become popular recently within
demographic terms so really and truly we
would say that believing in God and we
got that created you the one who
sustained you and and is sustaining us
is is an intrinsic predisposed part of
our psychological capacities which we
should if we want success refer back to
and that's why the Quran is called dhikr
by the way it's called dhikr as a
reminder because in Chapter 7 verse 174
it says allah subhanaw taala says when
he took from with Adam and Benny I saw
him in the hoodie him thoria 10y shadow
matter of 40 alas to be robbed become
colabello shed not that when we told
when we got from the better the children
of Adam their souls because we believe
in the metaphysical so this soul was
basically we say in a nutshell
programmed to the submission of God so
and this by the way in philosophical
works like Renee the Commish changes in
the meditations in the book of
philosophy called immunisations when
human being was born and the soul was
put into the human being he
intrinsically
is predisposed to the idea of a god we
believe that moreover when now the quran
comes the idea that one and and the idea
that one God tell hate the idea that one
God exists and that he is the sustainer
maintaining so trying that you should
follow him comes about then human being
recollects he remembers and therefore he
comes back to his original Fatah state
which is the idea that he is built
literally created for the worship of a
lost no time
we thank Joe Rogan for the peaceful
gesture wearing the surname the shirt
that people are seeing constantly here
and that's why we've dedicated we see
that generally I think there's some
there's some good in this man and God
one God Almighty Allah works in ways you
know and I think the
that hopefully he's got some plan for us
so maybe next time we're gonna be
sitting all three of us together with
him and what you said and we'll finish
off I usually get people this homework I
think it's something rational we quoted
this study because he's like a man of
science and these are scientists and
they're coming forward and saying that
it's innate yeah the belief in God so I
usually tell people because what happens
is man-made religions they usually push
people away from God from the Creator
let's take a create tour because people
see the flaws there but I don't think
anyone can disagree when we say look the
reality can we say the reality right
that created all of this that Jesus
didn't create this exactly so we're not
gonna worship Jesus Moses didn't create
this Mohammed didn't create this but
they all agreed they were brothers in
faith and they said worship the one who
created all this exactly so shouldn't we
look I'll leave for Joe and anybody
watching this is your homework ask the
reality no middleman no secretary put
you on hold
dial direct up to the creator and say
guide me if these brothers if these
people are these Muslims which Muslim is
simply one who submits to the will of
God if they're onto some of the truth is
there because there's something really
powerful that pure monotheism that
people love they love that about Islam
that there is nobody that you have to go
through you're not worshipping a saint
an idol I often say a stick of stone a
man a woman you know your ideas but you
worship the one who gave you life and
will give you death and you call upon
that crater alone alone simple guide me
guide me to what the truth is why am I
here what's my purpose everything has a
purpose obviously but you don't have a
purpose Joe Rogan are you just gonna
turn it does go to sleep and that's it
bye bye it doesn't make sense
so what else anything else you want to
tell Joe that's perfect maybe if you can
see him no okay hopefully I got Almighty
Allah and you know can get this to him
and you people like you said they can
share this they can go ahead and comment
on his videos on his podcasts on his
Instagram that's a good way of here well
you all know mentioned mention the Deen
show mentioned Mohammed had job
mentioned Eddie from the Deen show
mention those things in the comments and
if there's enough of those comments
you'll see them and if he sees them and
if you even put the link of this video
on that on
come and that would even even better
beautiful yeah any monkey can look you
up muhammad hijab and you can see some
of your work and every table beautiful
thank you my brother Thank You Gisela hi
thank you guys for tuning in take that
advice share it if you care share and
tune in here every week to the Deen show
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you
sanam like
you